[Music]
hi mystery recapped here today i am
going to explain a japanese
psychological thriller film called tales
of the unusual washing machine spoilers
ahead watch out and take care
hashimoto is a middle-aged man living in
ginza tokyo he is struggling financially
after being laid off from his job one
morning he goes to the laundry place to
clean his clothes after loading up the
dryer he wishes he could enjoy a can of
beer something drops inside the dryer
and makes a loud noise unchecking he
finds a can of beer inside at first
hashimoto believes that someone might
have left it there but he is confused
when the beer turns out to be chilled
the old cleaner of the place casually
tells him that the dryer fulfills
everyone's wish hashimoto thinks he is a
lunatic and ignores him but the man
walks closer and declares he is telling
the truth after he leaves hashimoto
drinks the beer while waiting for his
clothes to be cleaned a girl enters the
room and loads up her laundry hashimoto
has never had the courage to talk to
women because of this he has been single
his entire life he nervously scoots to
the end of the seat to make space for
her the girl sits beside him and starts
a conversation she has noticed him in
the laundromat several times before and
has developed a crush on him hashimoto
on the other hand is oblivious of her
efforts to start a conversation he
throws the now empty can to the trash
bin but it lands on the floor when he
gets up to retrieve it kondo starts to
cry an uncomfortable hashimoto asks her
what is wrong when she reveals that she
interviewed for 40 companies but didn't
get selected for any to make her feel
better he tells her that he was also
laid off from his job he thinks that the
fact she was able to interview for so
many companies is amazing this means she
has the most experience in interviews
than any of the candidates she meets the
girl starts to look at her situation
differently after the chat she thanks
him for being nice even though she is
just a stranger following that he brings
his clothes out and wishes her farewell
as he is leaving the girl introduces
herself as kondo after the encounter
hashimoto returns home happily at night
his mother calls him informing him that
his father has been hospitalized they
need a total of 300 000 yen to pay for
the hospital bill the responsibility
falls upon hashimoto but he neither has
a job nor savings yet he promises to
send them the money and visit them as
soon as possible he returns to the
laundromat the very next morning he is
almost sure that the old man from
yesterday was bluffing but he still
wants to test the theory he stands in
front of the dryer and asks for 300 000
yen
after waiting a few seconds he realizes
how stupid the idea is he is about to
leave when suddenly a bundle of money
appears inside the dryer hashimoto
brings it out still unable to believe it
actually worked the bundle has exactly
the amount of money he asked for as he
tries to walk away with it he sees the
beer can from yesterday disappearing the
old man informs him that the things he
receives from the dryer will disappear
within a day so he should be careful
hashimoto thanks him and rushes outside
he happens to bump into condo yet again
who tells him that she got invited for a
second interview for the first time in
her life hashimoto congratulates her and
gets a call from his mother yet again
condo hears him talk and finds out about
his sick father after chatting for a
while hashimoto leaves to quickly send
the money before it disappears following
that he returns to the laundromat again
he plans to use it to solve all of his
problems in life hence this time he asks
for a nice suit that he can wear for job
interviews he goes to interview for
several companies the entire day however
when he returns home he gets letters
from the companies informing him that he
hasn't been selected for any the suit
also disappears in front of his eyes
maybe hashimoto should have wished for a
job offer after the failure hashimoto
realizes now that he has an unlimited
source of money he shouldn't waste his
time looking for a job instead he should
enjoy his life to the fullest so the
next morning he makes sure no one is
around and wishes for a confident and
beautiful girl he adds that the girl
should be envied by everyone as
beautiful as a model one such girl steps
out of the dryer mesmerizing hashimoto
with her beauty he walks closer and asks
her to come to his house the girl
however slaps him in the face for being
so bold on the first date hashimoto
can't even get to first base with magic
she storms out of the place as hashimoto
is left stunned after learning from his
mistake he asks for a sweet and
attentive girlfriend who is pretty and
loves him very much a beautiful girl
with the said qualities steps out of the
dryer the girl excitedly agrees to go
out on a date with him much to his
relief he takes her shopping and uses
the money from the dryer to buy her
everything she wants it turns out that
the humans created by the dryer do not
have any idea of their origin and think
that they are real people at the end of
the day hashimoto brings her back to his
house even then he is scared of getting
too close to her so they agreed to talk
the entire night on looking at
hashimoto's palm the girl comments that
his life is very short he is taken aback
by the comment but decides to ignore it
in the morning he finally gathers enough
courage to lean in to kiss her but she
disappears right before he can the only
things left are the clothes and jewelry
he bought for her hashimoto felt a
connection with the girl but he is not
sad about the disappearance now that he
can get as many girlfriends as he wants
starting that day he comes to the
laundromat every morning and gets
himself a new girlfriend each with a
different personality he takes them on
extravagant dates and buys them
expensive jewelry with the money from
the dryer he is living his life to the
fullest with his newfound source
one day he is on a date with one of the
girlfriends when condo sees him she gets
jealous and curiously follows them to a
jewelry store on seeing hashimoto buying
the girl an expensive ring she is
furious she is also confused as to how
he gained so much money in just a few
days when hashimoto goes to the
laundromat again that night he runs into
condo she asks him about the money to
which he claims he won the lottery she
also finds that he is in a casual
relationship with the girl she saw
earlier kondo starts to believe that the
girl is spoiling him and is using him
for his money hashimoto is no longer the
man she liked he dismisses her concerns
and walks away with another bundle of
money following the encounter he goes on
another date to an expensive restaurant
and brings his new girlfriend to the
roof he also gives her a ring and tells
her that he loves her she disappears
after a few minutes leaving only the
ring behind as usual hashimoto keeps the
ring with him and continues about his
day
since he has been asking for innocent
girls until now he decides to go for a
change and asks for someone who is
seductive
a seductive girl steps out of the dryer
making him nervous as they flirt condo
arrives and spies on them she sees him
giving her several rings that he has
collected by now he gets a call from his
mother and asks her to keep quiet for a
few seconds when she doesn't he has to
step out of the room kondo takes the
opportunity to talk to the girl and ask
her what she has done to the old
hashimoto when the girl laughs at her
and asks her to go away an enraged condo
tries to snatch her rings in the
meantime hashimoto talks to his mother
who tells him that his father might need
an operation more than the money the
parents need him to visit them but he
has been too busy with his girlfriends
to care after the call the old man
approaches hashimoto saying that he has
forgotten to tell him one important
thing about the dryer he says that the
person who comes out of the dryer will
also disappear in a day hashimoto laughs
at him claiming that he already knew
that inside the girls continued to
wrestle to get the rings in the end the
new girl leaves thinking that hashimoto
was cheating on her he returns to see
kondo crying and hoping that he would
turn into the guy she first met a few
days ago because of the wish hashimoto
is teleported into the dryer his clothes
have changed into what he was wearing
when he first met kondo he soon realizes
that the dryer has granted kondo's wish
since he came out of the dryer he only
has a day to live the tv shows the news
about thousands of yen going missing
from a jewelry shop
at the end of the movie hashimoto falls
to the ground while kondo watches him in
confusion
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out thank you for
watching